this is Startalk this is from yahwah and
she says Queens New York made of asking
isn't there a fundamental difference
between genetically modified foods and
the cultivation of foods is there
fundamental so I think by cultivation
she I think she means traditional
hybridizing mm-hmm where you would take
the pollen from one plant shake it on to
the eggs the OVA of another plant and
see what happened and get a hybrid yeah
so George Washington is said to have
done this sounds sexy it is literal it's
that's the same no no this is what
happened to nature we have two sexes
males and females okay but but in fungi
it is believed certain species have
hundreds of sex types
aha that's a whole nother deal out there
in the land of fungus so what happens
clearly in the land of funk it's so
humans have been hybridizing within
species shaking pollen from one plant
onto the eggs of another okay
for centuries shake it baby but we found
out that not only in nature not only do
humans now biotechnologists have the
ability to take genes from one species
and insert them into another for example
that bacillus thuringiensis bacterium
gene into the corn-soybean making bt
soybeans BT corn right which the corn
borer eats the protein from the Baron
bacillus thuringiensis crystallizes in
the corn borers gut and the corn bored
it dies what so that's raw that's the
deal so that's why the corn borer is not
a problem anymore instead of fighting
these or these pets you let the plant do
the fighting for you instead of fighting
the pests with chemicals death we're
empowering the plant to do it oh that's
right that's right so you do it as
carefully as you can to be sure but the
other thing that was discovered recently
as I mentioned in our recent show is
that sweet potatoes
this way of example yeah this happened
it naturally virus got its genes in
sweet potatoes the ones that we know and
love and we supported that as
cultivators of sweet potatoes and
encouraged that in nature so what
happens in nature and now we're doing it
scientifically or bio technologically
and the difference really becomes blurry
whether its natural or humans are doing
a right because while we're kind of
doing is mimicking what nature has
already that's done yeah so the whole
thing though your concern is if you're
doing it so fast that you're gonna do
something in the ecosystem that nobody
anticipated and you don't want the
so-called knock-on or unintended
consequences right and the classic uses
are babies or something like you know
yes yeah like the Jurassic Park that's
what I'm sayin lizard babies or you know
or a ninja elegent dinosaur yes named
Charlie there's all sorts of trouble
with that right that and the unintended
consequence that really did happen in
nature through humans we developed this
we people developed this herbicide
called glyphosate kills all the weeds
kills all of everything everything
except the plants that have this cool
gene in them that allows them to grow
right through it
we also killed the milkweed in the
milkweed which I now prefer to call milk
flour Oh is what yes is what the monarch
butterflies rely on oh really
yeah so we accidentally have decimated
the monarch butterfly population reduced
it over the last two decades by ninety
percent which is probably a good thing
because when they flap their wings over
here it causes a pretty bad storm engine
oh this is the butterfly effect that's
seriously it's brilliant really good
it's so the thing is you don't want that
where you're accidentally wiping out a
pollinator or potential pollinator
species right so I went to the meeting
in Minneapolis the monarch venture where
they got the crazy bleeding-heart
liberal hippies okay like me and the
corporate pigs
like ConAgra monsanto doubt pioneer boo
anybody they all got together they all
want to bring monarchs back and they
believe that they can by creating this
so-called hopscotch highway of milk
flowers gotcha
growing these milk weeds on purpose
right in certain tracts of land on the
fly ways that the Monarchs exploit
getting north and so and along their
migration plan path you purposely put
this milk flower they have a monarch
filling station from north to south
that's it and along the way they're
doing a little butterfly horizontal
mambo and we get more and more monarchs
that's right so they're the prediction
of the venture this group that met in
Minneapolis diverse group people that
you would not think getting along are
all in this together say as an observer
they're all in this getting along they
believe that this year the monarch
population will go back up Wow one test
is worth a thousand expert opinion so
stay tuned and let's see if the Monarchs
come back yeah you go look all right
people
there you have it this is Startalk